-Republicans at the
Conservative
Political Action Conference
this weekend
cheered low vaccination rates
as COVID cases were rising
in states where
vaccinations have lagged.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The Trump era revealed a lot
about our politics,
but one main thing is
that many prominent Republicans
are just super weird.
[ Laughter ]
Here, for example,
is Donald Trump Jr.
just being super weird
while trying to tell
some incomprehensible jokes
at the Conservative
Political Action Conference
in Dallas over the weekend.
-Texas has always
led the charge.
[ Cheering
and applause ]
Well, 'til about like
a couple of months ago,
and then,
Austin sort of took over.
Like I don't know, guys.
Like Texas was leading
the charge.
You're still Top 25.
[ Laughter ]
But we got to work on that stuff
because those people
have lost their minds.
[ Isolated cheering
and applause ]
Right?
-California!
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
Last time somebody
bombed that badly,
he became the Joker.
[ Laughter ]
Don Jr. looked like he just
walked into a scene
in a student improv show
and blanked.
Don, you said freeze.
You got to have something.
Why is he looking
off to the side?
Is the Sandman there,
about to sweep him
off the stage?
Don Jr. has all the charm
and charisma
of a dude selling time-shares
in a hotel conference room
whose PowerPoint just crashed.
[ As Don Jr ]
Texas has so many
great opportunities,
as you can see here.
Okay, nope.
[ Laughter ]
Not getting a picture here,
but we know -- we know
the big towns in Texas, right?
[ Laughter ]
Dallas.
How-ston.
[ Laughter ]
Saint Tonio.
That's not right.
Oh, I think I'm going
to pass out.
[ Laughter ]
It's one thing
to be a Republican
and believe Republican things,
but they always take it
to such weird extremes,
like Tennessee
Senator Marsha Blackburn,
who, for some reason,
last week decided
to go on a bizarre rant
about how, under socialism,
Taylor Swift wouldn't be
allowed to perform music.
-When I'm talking to my friends
who are musicians
and entertainers
I say, "If -- If -- we have
a socialistic government,
if we have Marxism,
you are going to be the first
ones who will be cut off
because the state would have
to approve your music."
And, you know,
Taylor Swift came after me
in my 2018 campaign,
but Taylor Swift would be
the first victim of that
because, when you look
at Marxist socialist societies,
they do not allow women
to dress or sing or be onstage
or to entertain or the type
music that she would have.
-First of all,
what you're describing sounds
like a record company,
not socialism.
Second, even if you were
a repressive dictator,
the last person you'd want to go
after would be Taylor Swift
because she will write a song
about your bad behavior
and it will be
the song of the summer
and even your closest friends
will sing along to it
at barbecues you are at
and then, when they make
eye contact with you,
they'll pretend like
they're not singing along,
but you'll know they were.
They were.
[ Laughter ]
And they'll say, "Hey, are you
the guy in fatigues
who's fatiguing her?"
And you'll be like,
"I don't know.
It could be anybody,"
but you'll know it's you.
[ Laughter ]
But it's true.
Everyone knows that,
in countries with robust
social welfare programs,
women are not allowed
to sing or be onstage.
That's why the Icelandic
government famously tried
to outlaw Bjork,
until she raised
an army of me.
And that's today's jork,
♪♪
which is an Icelandic word,
meaning "joke about Bjork."
[ Laughter ]
Now, to be clear, I have no idea
what Blackburn is talking about.
It's hard to make sense
of what goes
through these people heads.
It's like trying
to follow directions
from an annoyed Parisian.
I think he said the Louvre is
inside that McDonald's?
I think what he said was,
"That's your Louvre."
That seems very rude.
With that said,
do you want to go to McDonald's?
[ Laughter ]
So Republicans think the left
wants to ban music.
They're also now arguing
that the Biden administration
is going to use
COVID vaccine outreach
as an excuse to come to your
door and invade your privacy.
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
tweeted last week...
Ted, please stop using slang
like G-man.
You sound like
a rejected Dick Tracy villain.
[ As Pacino ]
Beardsy McScraggle is in charge
of our getaway.
[ As Cruz ]
Good news, Big Boy.
I booked us all
on a flight to Cancun.
Bad news.
It comes back tomorrow.
[ As Pacino ]
I want Beardsy McScraggle dead!
[ Laughter ]
Pacino got Oscar-nominated
for that role
and, for that,
the academy should be applauded.
And, yes, I spent the last
two weeks at impression camp.
[ Laughter ]
As a counselor!
Republicans have to spin
elaborate conspiracy theories
about otherwise humane,
sensible policies
because that's all they have.
It's not threatening or ominous
to raise awareness
about vaccines.
That's why there was never
a straight-to-video
Steven Seagal movie called...
Although I do think
I just saw a trailer
for a new Liam Neeson movie
called...
...where he rides
in a literal wagon
and welcomes a gang to town.
[ As Neeson ]
With his fists.
I think you'll find
we have a nice library
and a lovely park,
but you really want to check out
our graveyard.
We didn't get to that
at Impressions camp.
[ Laughter ]
[Clap]
Because you made me come back!
[ Laughter ]
It makes sense to go
to communities
where vaccination rates
are lagging
and reach out
to people directly,
especially since,
in those same places,
COVID cases are,
once again, rising.
It's not
about government control.
It's about saving lives.
CBS reported this weekend
that...
I can't believe
it's even necessary
to say that, but here we are.
It's like saying
all the red people at the beach
are the ones
who didn't wear sunscreen.
[ Laughter ]
We know what the
sunscreen's for.
There's nothing nefarious
about community outreach
to get more people
to take life-saving vaccines.
Just listen to Biden
describe the plan.
-Now, we need to go
community by community,
neighborhood by neighborhood,
and, ofttimes,
door to door,
literally knocking on doors,
to get help
to the remaining people.
-All he's talking about is
raising awareness
in areas
with low vaccination rates.
Joe Biden isn't going
to personally knock
on your door.
The only time Biden's
ever knocked
on a neighbor's door is
to let them know
he's about to set off
a ton of fireworks.
[ As Biden ]
I just wanted to give you
the heads up,
in case it freaks out your dog.
[ Laughter ]
We desperately need
elected leaders
and influential Republicans
to help get as many people
vaccinated as possible,
especially since a lot
of the people refusing the shots
are Trump supporters
in deep red states.
And, yet, instead,
Republicans are spreading
insane conspiracy theories
about Biden's community
outreach plan,
purely as a political tactic
to scare voters.
-Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeting this --
"Biden pushing a vaccine
that is NOT FDA approved..."
-We're here to tell government
we don't want your benefits.
We don't want your welfare.
Don't come knocking on my door
with your Fauci ouchie.
You leave us the hell alone!
-And, now, they're starting
to talk about going door to door
to be able to take vaccines
to the people.
Think about the mechanisms
they would have to build
to be able to actually execute
that massive of a thing
and then, think about what
those mechanisms
could be used for.
They could then go door to door,
take your guns.
They could then go door
to door, take your Bible.
-You think the government has
to build a whole new mechanism
to go door to door to raise
awareness about vaccines,
which they could then use
to take away Bibles
and your guns?
Have you ever heard
of the Postal Service?
Imagine government workers going
door to door in their high socks
and their bucket hats
and their short shorts,
coming to your house to take
away your Bibles and your guns
and your outgoing mail.
Next thing you're going to know,
they're going to tell you
I need to put a stamp
on my mail
and that I can't just stuff
the cute neighborhood cat
in the box
and write "Abu Dhabi" on it.
Well, last I checked,
mailing a cat to Abu Dhabi
was my God-given,
constitutional right.
What's next,
I'm not allowed to hate Mondays?
[ Laughter ]
COVID cases are,
once again, on the rise,
especially in parts
of the country
where vaccination rates
are lagging
and a contagious new variant
is spreading.
We desperately need to get
as many people vaccinated
as possible.
The evidence that these vaccines
are safe and effective
is overwhelming,
from both clinical trials
and real-world studies.
And yet, over the weekend,
attendees at the CPAC
cheered the news
that the Biden administration
has not been able
to get as many Americans
vaccinated as they hoped for.
-They were hoping,
the government was hoping,
that they could sort of sucker
90% of the population
into getting vaccinated
and it isn't happening, right?
[ Cheering and applause ]
Younger people
are well aware
of what the risks really are.
-Ugh! That's
the political equivalent
of clapping when a waiter
drops some dishes.
That's the worst thing
I've ever seen a crowd cheer for
since Alice Cooper bit the head
off a live chicken onstage.
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, maybe it happened
in 1969,
but maybe I was there.
You don't know.
Maybe I'm secretly
in my late 60s.
Ever wonder what I look like
before I shave
and put on all this makeup?
Here's a pic
from our hiatus last week
and I look good!
[ Laughter ]
I'll work on those old-man abs.
Every morning at 5:00 am,
I swim the length
of the East River
and then, I meet up
with Wally at the gym.
He counts my squats
via cue card.
[ Laughter ]
This is what
the Republican Party
and right-wing media
have wrought --
a movement that celebrates
low vaccination rates
and spins
insane conspiracy theories
about attempts to get
more people to take
a life-saving vaccine.
If Republicans
had any shame at all,
they'd look inward and ask
themselves how they got here,
but they won't because...
-Those people
have lost their minds.
[ Isolated cheering
and applause ]
Right?
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.